et vous devez le voir rod caire fait
partie des startups sélectionnées dans
le sprint 50 avant de rejoindre son
créateur découverte d'abord de
l'entreprise à l'initiative de cette
start up il s'agit de diagou et suivez
moi on va rejoindre son fondateur
[Musique]
philip ryan est avec nous bonjour
bonjour vous êtes le directeur de
développement de diagou et diagou et
c'est une société créée en 2015 à
montigny-le-bretonneux 15 collaborateurs
aujourd'hui un chiffre d'affaires d'un
peu plus d'un million d'euros
et puis votre activité c'est
l'ingénierie routière vous êtes un peu
le docteur le médecin des routes c'est
ça exactement nous auscultent on les
routes pour en faire pour en déterminer
des pathologies et pourrait également
aider les gestionnaires à l'entretien
donc à déterminer quelles sont les
maladies des routes alors justement
qu'est-ce qu'on retrouve comme type de
pathologie alors on peut retrouver des
pathologies on mesure ce qu'on appelle
le profil transversale par exemple quand
vous avez de leurs mirage leurs mirage
c'est un aspect de confort mais
également de sécurité routière puisqu'il
peut y avoir des de rétention d'eau et
dans ce cas là on peut pas refaire un
aquaplaning
voilà un des exemples mais aussi les
nids-de-poule les fissures qui se sont
un peu plus précis d'ailleurs bien sûr
les nids de poule les fissures les
arrachements les réparations toutes les
toutes les pathologies toutes les
dégradations qu'on peut voir à la
surface lorsqu'on circule en voiture
alors qu'ils sont vos clients nos
clients ce et les maîtres d'ouvragé
publics et privés
ça va de la petite commune qui à 50 km à
gérer ou à la société concessionnaire
qui ont plusieurs milliers de kilomètres
à gérer ou des départements
vous êtes écrit en 2015 l'entreprise est
à peu près six ans comment elle évolue
elle est en forte croissance
nous avons de plus en plus de demandes
dans le domaine de l'auscultation pour
les collectivités locales et
territoriales
alors vous venez de vous présenter votre
activité une activité donc de diagnostic
de l'état des routes et vous utilisez
diagou et 1
donc c'est l'un des véhicules qu'on voit
derrière noah oui c'est un des véhicules
que nous utilisons dans le domaine de
l'auscultation notamment pour les
réseaux départementaux et les réseaux
communaux alors on voit sur ces images
il circule et en même temps il capte
l'image comment ça fonctionne tel outil
on voit aussi sur le sur le camion alors
sur le camion vous pouvez voir il ya
différents outils il ya notamment aux
mesures qu'on appelle le profil
transversale donc les déformations
transversale mais également le profit de
l'original donc le confort le confort au
niveau des de l'usager et mais également
la macro texture c'est une des
composantes de la de l'adhérence donc de
la sécurité routière
et puis l'outil innovant s'érode caire
c'est votre spin off
une entreprise a été créée au sein de
dia gouët et justement on va rejoindre
antonal en selle pour parler de rhodes
caire
[Musique]
rod caire est une jeune start-up
puisqu'elle a été créée le 1er février
2021 et nous sommes avec son co
fondateur antonin mancelle bonjour
bonjour alors road caire doit sa sa
naissance à diagou et l'entreprise dans
laquelle nous sommes
le puisque or au caire propose une
solution de diagnostic des routes sur
une application c'est ça exactement en
fait routière est une spin off de jag
way et c'est la version simplifiée du
diagnostic routier c'est à dire qu'on
n'a pas besoin de camions avec tous les
équipements on a juste besoin d'un
smartphone d'une application est la
nouveauté c'est que c'est également
directement la collectivité qui peut
réaliser le diagnostic ont régi avec son
smartphone et d'autres applications
quand ça fonctionne en fait alors il
suffit de télécharger l'application nous
il faut avoir un smartphone ou
téléchargent des applications fixes le
smartphone sur le pare brise
ensuite il suffit de rouler on parcourt
donc le gestionnaire parcours sont
linéaires il scanne son réseau nous on
récupère la donner hélas données
collectées et analysées sur nos serveurs
par l'intelligence artificielle
donc c'est là où tout l'inventaire se
fait des dégradations une poule les
fissures et toute la restitution se fait
ensuite sur sur une interface full web
donc le gestionnaire une fois de retour
au bureau se connecte avec son mail et a
accès à tout l'inventaire des
dégradations qui est réalisé aux notes
de bon
des moyens et aussi au plan de travaux
que l'on propose suite à ce diagnostic
vous dites l'intelligence artificielle
c'est elle qui va analyser l'état des
routes c'est à dire concrètement il ya
une fissure
elle identifie sur la route c'est ça en
fait on a justement grâce à thiago est
une énorme base d'image une base de
données qui sont déjà analysé donc on a
fait apprendre à la machine à
reconnaître ces dégradations et donc de
cette manière on peut le faire de façon
automatisée à grande échelle
donc ça à la fois plus rapide et aussi
plus objectif parce que l'intelligence
artificielle fera toujours les mêmes
choix et elle va pas entre le matin ou
le soir changer de grille de critères
cette solution est destinée à un client
particulier enfin un groupe de clients
en tout cas les collectivités et
notamment les communes qui n'ont pas
forcément les moyens pour payer investir
dans une étude assez globale sur l'ordre
réseau routier c'est tout à fait ça les
communes ont des budgets restreints
d'entretien de la voirie et donc c'est
vrai que souvent la partie étude et mise
à la trappe
nous ce que l'on propose c'est d'avoir
une étude alors qu'il fera pas tout ce
que pourra faire dire oui mais qui
permettra d'avoir un premier état
initial un premier diagnostic et des
pistes de solution et qui permettra
d'accompagner la collectivité dans
justement la gestion de sa compétence
voirie en lui donnant des données qui
sont fiables sur son lait qui sont
actualisable sur son réseau routier
merci anthony man c'est avec grand
plaisir le cofondateur de hohrod caire
une aventure entrepreneuriale qu'on
suivra bien sûr c'est notre antenne